Hogwarts Legacy has been steadily
dropping new bits of information about
the game's story specifically the
backstory of the three companions that
have been confirmed so far now I put out
a question on my YouTube Community page
for you guys basically asking how you
feel about these drops that we've got so
far I want to be very clear that I am
not complaining here in any way however
I'm starting to hear from a lot of
people that they really don't want to
see more information on the game's story
and so I asked you guys what do you
think are we getting too much info on
the story and so here are the results 34
said yeah I'd rather go in blind on the
story details 49 said good balance so
far but we don't need any more on the
story and then 16 said nope keep the
story drops coming so the story details
that I'm talking about here are all
about the three recent character card
reveals that we got from Nat's ionai our
Gryffindor companion Sebastian sallow
our Slytherin companion and Poppy
Sweeting our Hufflepuff companion and I
do have just a little bit of something
for the ravenclaws at the end of the
video don't worry I'm not gonna forget
you guys even if Avalanche seems to be
doing just that so far now when you look
at each of these poppies barely revealed
anything at all poppy is a bright and
compassionate girl with extensive
knowledge of and a deep love for
creatures in fact she believes creatures
have far more redeeming qualities than
most people and has a particular
aversion to poachers and those who work
with them now let's jump back to the
trailer when we were first revealed to
Poppy which said this puppy Sweeting has
a kind heart and loves magical beasts
connecting with them more easily than
with humans that's what happens now so
really the only new addition that we
have with the card here is the fact that
she has a particular aversion to poters
which isn't really surprising when you
consider her love for magical creatures
which we already knew about from the
trailer now for those of you who follow
the channel for a while you know that I
have been all in on this idea of
poachers for a while now I posted a
theory way back before we even had the
gameplay reveal trailer I just thought
there were too many things adding up
showing that magical creatures and
specifically someone harming these
magical creatures was going to play a
key role in the game and now we have
that confirmed here yet again now what's
interesting is when you think about the
Autodesk session we actually got a cut
scene there where the main character and
natsai onai were attempting to help a
hippogriff that had been subdued and
taken captive by these poachers so while
I'm sure that there are going to be a
number of story lines throughout the
game and we've already had it confirmed
that the quest with Sebastian sallow is
completely optional I assume that the
quests with poppy and the quest with
natsight are going to be optional as
well we don't know that for certain yet
but I would think it would be the same
as Sebastian all that being said I am
still fully expecting that the storyline
of poachers and magical creatures are
going to play a very big role in this
game here I don't know if it's Rookwood
behind it I don't know if it's rain Rock
behind it or if it's some other group
entirely perhaps they're led by this
mask wizard here which we actually did
not see any of these guys in the more
recent trailers personally it's not that
I mind seeing little details like this
I'm just ready for gameplay I'm ready
for the stuff that's really going to
show what kind of game this is going to
be but let's move on now to now Hat's
eye and if you're going to reveal story
stuff about the game I think this one is
a perfect example of how to do it
because really all we get with natsai is
backstory it's setting this up and
helping us to get to know her a little
bit before we actually start the game
however unlike Sebastian which we're
going to talk about that one again here
in a second I feel like his gets
involved a little bit more with the
current story of Hogwarts Legacy whereas
natsai seems to be like it's just mostly
providing backstory for us so here is
this one wise quick-witted and possessed
of a need to seek Justice natsai grew up
in matabelle land Africa where she
attended wagadu the largest Wizarding
School in the world I looked up both
those pronunciations so if I'm wrong I
blame the internet she transferred to
Hogwarts when her mother became the
school's divination professor and is
adapting to her new life in Scotland so
I really like this one we get this big
bit of news right here that she is a
transfer student essentially she did not
start out at Hogwarts so it makes sense
that she and our main character are
going to be able to bond over the fact
that they are both new to Hogwarts so
they're both meeting new people plus
natsai also has the added piece of her
mother actually being a professor now
when it comes to wagadu this school
actually has an extensive write-up on
wizardingworld.com one of the details
being what we just learned there in the
card that it is the largest Wizarding
school now I definitely think you should
go and read the whole thing if you
haven't already but I'm gonna pull out
what I think are some key bits of
information here starting with this
right here the last sentence of the
first paragraph much some would say all
magic originated in Africa and wagadu
graduates are especially well-versed in
astronomy Alchemy and
self-transfiguration so when you think
about all of magic originating in Africa
or even if not all of it a very large
portion of it now I think we could also
take from this that it seems highly
likely that Africa maybe even wagadu
itself is also a stronghold of ancient
magic could there be a moment in the
game where we need to seek out professor
onai and she's going to inform us a
little bit about ancient magic in Africa
possibly even how it all connects to
Hogwarts and the greater Wizarding World
as a whole honestly of all the details
that we've learned on the character so
far this one I find is super exciting
I've always been fascinated since we
first learned about the other Wizarding
World schools on The Wizarding World
website I've always wanted to learn more
and see more of these in books or film
whatever it may be possibly even future
games and again maybe even this game
okay yeah yeah I know expectations keep
them in check the next bit of
interesting information comes right
immediately at the beginning of that
next paragraph the wand is a European
invention and while African witches and
wizards have adopted it as a useful tool
in the last century many spells are cast
simply by pointing the finger or through
hand gestures now this one also ties
back into ancient magic because not all
forms of this ancient magic we don't
know exactly how it's going to manifest
itself in this game but what we know
from the lore of the series is that it
does not require wands and while I
personally still don't think that we'll
be able to become an animagus in the
game if there's going to be any chance
at seeing one then it is definitely
going to be natsai or her mother when
you consider this line right here many
older and more experienced witches and
wizards felt threatened by 14 year olds
who could turn at will into elephants
and cheetahs so if they were going to
try and fit becoming an animagus into
Hogwarts Legacy then I certainly think
it's very likely that natsai and her
mother maybe even our Transfiguration
Professor would play a role now the next
story detail that I want to talk about
here is also relating to natsai and it's
the fact that her mother is the
Divination Professor does that confirm
that we'll be able to take divination as
a class given that we already had the
reveal of the Divination tower on the
Hogwarts Legacy Twitter account and now
we have the confirmed Professor for it I
think we can just about confirm it even
if it's not 100 I think we can 99 say
yes we will be having divination class
at some point in Hogwarts Legacy which
is an incredibly exciting thing to have
confirmed now for our next detail I'm
going to jump back to Sebastian salo's
card this is the one where we learned
not only his sister's name which is Anne
but also that they are twins and then
another mint function of the mysterious
debilitating curse now there's been a
lot of speculation among fans about what
this curse could potentially be I've
heard werewolf I've heard obscurial I've
heard vampire I still think the most
likely option is a blood maledictus so
according to the HP lexicon a maledictus
is a witch or wizard who suffers from a
blood curse one form of this Affliction
referred to as a malediction had been
inherited by Draco Malfoy's wife Astoria
Greengrass Astoria died from the blood
curse in August of 2019. this is
according to Harry Potter and the cursed
child for those of you who consider that
Canon now HB Lex gun also goes on to say
another form causes its victim to slowly
transform permanently into a beast and
this is what we see in the Fantastic
Beasts film specifically the crimes of
Grindelwald so one of the biggest
reveals that we have gotten so far from
the Fantastic Beasts films is the fact
that Knight Guinea yes the inagini from
the days of Harry Potter and Voldemort
was in fact a maledictus and used to be
a human being and if you're keeping
track here when it comes to the magical
creatures if this is to be the case and
she is suffering in fact from a
maladiction the kind that will have her
permanently transformed into a creature
well we just have yet another example of
how important magical creatures are
going to be in this game and one thing
that could actually tie all of these
companion quests together the Autodesk
cutscene showed us that natsai was
helping us on the mission to rescue High
Wing the hippogriff then we have
confirmed details about Poppy and how
she has this interesting bond with
magical creatures and she really does
not like the poachers then we also have
Sebastian here who is Seeking a cure for
his sister and this debilitating curse
which very well could be having her
transform permanently into a creature
now a lot of people may be discouraged
just thinking about that because we kind
of already know there's no cure for this
but I think there is one key idea that
could actually still work with the Canon
and us still find a way to save her and
that all comes back to ancient magic our
character we know has some sort of
mysterious ability and we have seen a
couple couple of ways that it's going to
manifest itself in game but perhaps we
haven't seen all the ways so if you're
holding out hope of saving Sebastian's
sister maybe it will in fact be possible
through ancient magic and honestly I'm
still fascinated to learn more about
maledictus in general maledictuses is
that the plural I mean once nagini
transformed into the snake permanently
did she retain her human memories are
they completely gone because I
definitely think we could see a scenario
where Sebastian and Poppy and the main
character and even natsai are helping
his sister and transition into this new
phase of life where maybe they
eventually have to come to a point of
acceptance where they know there is no
other way they're not going to be able
to keep her human so instead they're
going to try and prepare themselves to
take care of her as best they can once
she is fully transformed into a creature
again this is all if this actually ends
up being the curse that she's Afflicted
with now finally one more detail because
I don't want to leave out the ravenclaws
out there I know you guys are still
hoping waiting when are we gonna get
more info about a Ravenclaw companion
well while I cannot say win I have no
idea when we're going to be getting more
info about a Ravenclaw companion or even
if we will get info about a Ravenclaw
companion before launch but I talked to
one of the same folks that has given me
some information in the past about
Hogwarts Legacy you guys know we confirm
no playable quidditch long before it was
officially confirmed so take this for
what it's worth I can in fact confirm
that we will have a Ravenclaw companion
in this game honestly I was starting to
get a little bit worried after we had
that whole week where they showed us
three companions but nothing else it's
like oh man is this it are they really
not gonna have a Ravenclaw companion but
no guys it is definitely just a matter
of when not if there is a Ravenclaw
companion we also just got a ton of new
information regarding this field guide
and I have broken all of that down in
this video for you here on the right
side of your screen now as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon